>> Reporter: In the skies near
Japan f15 on the hunt for a
suspected north Korean
intercontinental ballistics
missile capturing what could be
last seconds in flight.
This rare video released by
Japan's military, experts say
the burning object resemble as
ballistic missile boost rocket
reentering the atmosphere flying
about an hour at hyper sonic
speeds.
>> If there's no interception,
an icbm launched from north
Korea would take a little bit
more than minutes to reach the
moment land depending if it's
the west coast or east coast
will have more time.
>> Chinese scientists simulate
add nuclear attack, according to
the south China morning post the
simulation shows 33 minutes from
the time of launch till the time
of impact.
If U.S. Missile defenses fail to
shoot down the icbm
>> Missile defense begins mere.
>> For years U.S. Leaders
reassured the public
>> The nation should be very
confident
>> And America's allies
>> Easily shoot them out of the
sky.
>> Motive defense systems can
keep them safe.
But virtually all ballistics
missiles travel at more than
five times the speed of sound.
Sometimes faster.
>> It's been described as
hitting a bullet with bullet.
Trying to hit a war head.
>> Three, two, one.
Ignition.
>> A report last year finding
America's missile defense system
the nation's best perhaps only
line of defense only succeeds
about half the time.
>> In North Korea were to fire a
nuclear arm at the united
States, we could not essential
our defense system would prevent
it.
>> A U.S. Missile defense
agency report last year said the
missile defense system
demonstrated a measured
capability to defend the united
States deployed forces and
allies from a rogue nation's
missile attack.
That rogue nation has a fast
growing arsenal.
Kim Jong-un military is mass
producing icbm's, he knows a
barrage of ballistic missiles
could be too much for the U.S.
To shoot down.
>> Well, it's pretty sobering
reporting, especially
considering so many of these
missile defense tests missile
defense shield tests have not
gone well for the United States.
You're talking about North Korea
specifically with these
missiles, what about missiles
that would start from China or
Russia?
>> This is the scary thing that
a lot of people probably don't
know.
Yes, you know, the U.S. Missile
defense system might be able to
defend against an attack from a
rogue state like North Korea as
long as the program doesn't get
too big, maybe Iran, but China,
Russia the size of their arrest
analysis to if they launched
nuclear missiles just like if
the U.S. Launched nuclear
missiles a them, there would be
no way to shoot anything close
to all of them down, this is the
definition of to mutually